quiero empezar recordando algunas
características de este 49.3 y es
precisamente que la única forma ahora
que queda para la oposición de tumbar la
reforma o debatirla sería presentar una
moción de censura contra El Ejecutivo y
que esta moción prosperar hay que por lo
tanto tomará al gobierno y a su reforma
pero es posible que esto ocurra
Pues en lo absoluto todo es posible
ahora para que nuestros oyentes
entienden bien cómo estamos y a dónde
estamos estamos hoy en día en una crisis
política
y como muy bien lo dijiste a raíz del
uso de un instrumento perfectamente
constitucional un artículo que se llama
el cuarenta y nueve punto tres que
permite como muy bien lo dijiste al
gobierno en discusión parlamentaria
sobre textos que llevan sobre proyectos
financieros o de financiación de seguros
sociales lo que lo cual estamos ahora
para
imponer ese dispositivo y que separe el
voto y el texto está considerado como
adoptado salvo Sí en las veinticuatro
horas
se está poniendo pues una moción de
censura es decir que sí se hace
oposición a ese dispositivo a esa medida
tomada por el gobierno es lo que va a
pasar va a haber una moción de censura
de las oposiciones en esas veinticuatro
horas que van a ser discutida la semana
próxima habrá un voto sobre la moción o
las emociones de censura y ahí como bien
lo preguntas la mayoría siendo de 289
diputados sobre un total de quinientos
setenta y siete o las oposiciones logran
unirse y tener la mayoría y ahí tumba el
gobierno o está rechazo rechazado la la
moción de censura y y sigue la vida
parlamentaria y Pascal iremos siguiendo
la aritmética que se va dando respecto a
una eventual mayoría para estas mociones
de censura pero como usted viene decía
este artículo este instrumento sea
perfectamente constitucional es un
artículo de la Constitución sin embargo
qué mensaje envía Emmanuel macron con la
activación de este artículo para aprobar
un proyecto que recordemos cuenta con el
rechazo de la mayoría de la población
francesa ha convocado movilizaciones
masivas Emmanuel macron se ha negado de
hecho a reunirse con los líderes
sindicales y además utiliza su Victoria
electoral como instrumento de
legitimidad para pasar este proyecto a
pesar de que en su momento reconoció que
su Victoria fue más bien un rechazo a la
extrema derecha por lo tanto Qué mensaje
político está aquí mandando macron
bueno primero la reforma de sistema de
pensiones estaba en el programa de
Manuel eso lo tenemos que recordar ahora
cuál es el mensaje es decir que
definitivamente frente a esas
movilizaciones desde ocho días frente al
al momento de tensiones puede haber
quizás cristalización quiso parar
definitivamente y ahí el presidente en
Francia tiene en ese poder ejecutivo
tiene la fuerza política para influir
sobre los debates en este caso
parlamentarios en los debates públicos
Por qué te digo eso porque estamos
hablando de ese artículo que todos
estamos descubriendo mientras ha sido
usado muchas veces Desde que la desde
1958 Es decir desde que Francia entró en
la quinta república
instituciones en la cual vivimos hoy
definitivamente El Ejecutivo tiene el
poder entonces de influir sobre los
debates usando barrios dispositivos
constitucionales fiscal precisamente
Perdone que se nos acaba el tiempo
quería
acentuar en algo que usted estaba
diciendo y es que se ha usado un
centenar de veces este artículo podría
usted mencionar alguna de las veces más
emblemáticas en las que se ha utilizado
este instrumento para aprobar una ley de
grandes magnitudes en 1962
el entonces jefe de gobierno
enfrentó una moción de censura la moción
fue adoptada el gobierno fue derrumbado
el presidente china
disolvió porque es otro instrumento
constitucional en Francia el presidente
tiene el poder en disolver el parlamento
disolvió y ganó una mayoría jefe de
gobierno bajo franzo administrador
usó 28 veces el 49 y tres ahora la jefa
de gobierno actual Elizabeth borna lo
usa y esta vez es la el número once de
uso del actual gobierno Entonces es un
discurso positivo conocido usado para
definitivamente adoptar rápidamente unos
unos proyectos de ley para acabar unos
debates Y en este caso como preguntaste
esperando Pues que se calme tarde o
temprano las pensiones que estamos
viviendo